he used to right around the holidays
there was just certain things that I
didn't understand but I understood later
where we would just drive certain areas
and he just over a sudden open his door
he would pick up these home and you know
I'm I'm 10 years old yeah you know move
over move over you know and it's just
you him and a homeless guy a couple yeah
a couple yeah whatever you can fit in
three four you know whatever it was
that's a big heart and then he took him
to the hospital dropped them off so you
know I would ask questions after it was
all over with I'd say that they're sick
he goes well not not in a way well you
put him in the hospital mhm so he said
yeah and he tried to explain things to
me you know he would try he didn't talk
much unless you ask him something yeah
that kind of works and you know don't
talk unless someone ask you something
yeah and he he he explained to me that
he said um I saidwell why you put him in
the hospital then I you know and of
course the sickness was the alcoholics
but um why why you put him he's it
wasn't an alcohol rehab you know so why
you put and it wasn't for the purpose to
dry out he wasn't trying to cure them
yeah let's put that far before we we
anointed him for saood you know Like by
Teddy all so I I was like we we finally
get to the point why you put him in
there yeah well because it's the
holidays all right why you put them in
there well the holidays you know are
good for certain people and bad for
others and um and it was always before
the holidays it was before Christmas
before whatever and and um New Year's
whatever and so I said
why and he said
because they remind people certain
people of what they don't
have that you other people uh enjoy the
holidays because of what they have
family you know whatever and it reminds
them their mind is that that's pretty
profound yeah and and then I I don't
know remember because he didn't use the
word suicide but I I got it like he he
basically I forget how he said it but
like I just got it I don't know how I
got Osmos I don't know but I just got it
like so they don't hurt themselves that
that's what came across every way I
don't think he ever articulated that
ever verbalized that but yeah they don't
hurt themselves so and well how how does
that work well just basically they're
going to be around people they're not
going to be alone they're going to be
around people they're going to get fed
they're going to be warm right and it's
going to be for three days two three
days whatever and it's basically it's
it's a bridge so and the the funny thing
as a 10-year-old I I wanted
to I want to be connected to him so I i'
I've enlisted myself in a job when when
when he used to drop the off he he would
take them get them in right and
um and then the thing that I know again
he didn't say nothing but I you notice
things and if you care enough you don't
you don't notice nothing if you don't
care but if you care if it's important
you notice and this guy was important to
me I just was I didn't know what a hero
was no clue I love Mickey Mano I love
Willie May I love I I love Muhammad Ali
I I I never ever connected in my mind as
Heroes never my
father I I didn't connect it that way
but he looking back now looking back he
was he was my first connection to a hero
the two of you ever talk about how much
you love each
other one one thing that was uh not
allowed the the greatest memory I have
my father shown me love was we were down
in Florida at an airport and
and um we were I was born in Miami don't
ask me I was passing through and the
rest of my family was born in New York
stand now and so I was supposed to go
back with him right and I wanted to stay
with my mother for whatever reason and
so he you know he of course conceeded to
it and he's he's okay you know whatever
and very quiet very and this is a man
who never showed emotion to anyone MH I
mean for the most you know well all of a
sudden he just turned and kissed me on
the forehead and left and I was I was
like that's
different